داخل قبه القصر الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
التام الفاعلون في المشهد السياسي من اجل
التوقيع على اتفاق الاقاري ينص على اقامه
سلطه مدنيه بالكامل في كافه مستوياتها
السياديه والتنفيذيه والتشريعيه والتاكيد
على جيش المهني الواحد وملتزم بالعقيده
العسكريه الموحده
حضور دولي واقلي شهد حفل مراسم التوقيع
الذي جدد فيه البرهان التاكيد على خروج
الجيش من معادله السلطه وسياسه
العسكريه من العمليه السياسيه نهائيا
هذا الامر
يجب ان يصاحبه خروج القوى السياسيه من
المشاركه في مرحله انتقاليه
استجابه لمطلب الثوار
ما هذا لعوده المسار الديمقراطي في
السودان وقريبا ستبدا المرحله الاهم ان
شاء الله المرحله الثانيه نبدا فورا
بالمؤتمرات والورش يعني مناقشه القضايا
الاربعه والخمسه الان تحتاج الى تفاصيل
وتحتاج الى عمل جاد لكي نصل للاتفاق
النهايه خلال اربع اسابيع ان شاء الله
الاتفاق الايطالي سيبقى مفتوحا لاستيعاب
القوى المدنيه
المتحفظه على بنوده وستجر عمليات مشاورات
من اجل تطويره الى اتفاق النهائي
بتيسير من قوى دوليه واقليميه
بذلت جهود كبيره في تشجيع الاطراف
السودانيه
للحوار والوصول الى ما وصلوا اليه في هذه
المرحله ومازلنا نواصل هذا الاتجاه
لان موقف المملكه العربيه السعوديه هو
تحقيق الاستقرار ووحده السودان والازدهار
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي وقع في الخرطوم
بالرغم من انه حاضيه بمباركه دوليه
واقليميه الا ان البعض يقول انه قد يواجه
تحديات على الارض في ظل رفض بعض القوى
السياسيه وبعض لجان المقاومه
لجان المقاومه ارسلت رسائلها سريعا
بالخروج الى الشارع وعلى بعد كيلومترات
قليله من القصر الرئاسي اتجاه التنسيقيه
لجان المقاومه لتعبر عن رفضها للاتفاق
تعاملت معهم الشرطه بالغاز المثيل للدموع
وذلك يشكل استمرارا لمشهد يبدو ان سحب
ازماته لم تنشع حتى الان محمد عثمان
العربي الخرطوم